le centre aquatique de rambouillet enfin
rouvert ses portes samedi dernier après
cinq ans de rénovation l'espace est
désormais plus grand et mieux équipés on
a doublé les espaces on a construit un
bassin de 50 mètres avec une vraie
modularité et on a refait tous les
bassins existants les bassin
d'apprentissage le bassin de 25 m avec
intro mobile c'est une vraie une vraie
renaissance du centre aquatique les
yvelinois attendaient avec impatience
cette réouverture
et ils ne sont pas déçus c'est magique
c'est un vrai bonheur on a attendu ça
depuis très longtemps donc on est
vraiment très content les travaux ont
pris un peu plus de plus de temps que
prévu donc oui on l'attendait et ça fait
vraiment plaisir de voir de l'avoir
ouverte ces espaces permettront aussi
d'accueillir les sportifs on et aires de
jeux 2024 on a été labellisé donc on est
dans les rangs pour pouvoir accueillir
l'entraînement et des équipes de chaînes
internationales qui viendront pour les
jo 2000 24 ici sur rambouillet on est
prêt les accueillant les bassins
extérieurs sont encore en travaux ils
seront inaugurés en juin prochain une
bonne nouvelle pour la saison estivale